♪ ♪
>> President Trump: YOU DON'T
HAND MATCHES TO AN ARSONIST AND
YOU DON'T GIVE POWER TO AN ANGRY
LEFT-WING MOB, AND THAT'S WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME.
THEY WOULD TURN OUR COUNTRY SO
FAST INTO VENEZUELA, AND
VENEZUELA IS NOT DOING TOO WELL,
FOLKS.
>> IT'S TIME FOR US AS DEMOCRATS
TO BE AS TOUGH AS THEY ARE, AND,
WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE GO LOW.
NO, WHEN WE GO LOW -- WHEN THEY
GO LOW, WE KICK THEM.
>> IN RESPONSE TO THAT
STATEMENT, COLORADO SENATOR CORY
GARDNER JUST PUT OUT A TWEET
THAT SAYS, YOU HAVE OTHER PARTY
REDRESSING MICHELLE OBAMA WAS
WRONG, SHE SAID WHEN WE GO --
AFTER THE CAVANAGH VOTE.
IN THE MEANTIME THE PRESIDENT IS
CAMPAIGNING IN PENNSYLVANIA,
TWEETING OUT TO THE WHITE HOUSE
FROM ERIE, PENNSYLVANIA, I
CANNOT DISAPPOINT THE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
EVERYONE THIS EVENING.
EVEN AS HE HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE HURRICANE.
ANDY McCARTHY, FORMER CHIEF
ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY AND
COUNTRY BIDDING EDITOR AT
NATIONAL RADIO.
BYRON, LET ME START WITH YOU.
THE POLITICS AND PROTEST, MOBS
AND ANGER, HOW IS THIS ALL
PLAYING?
>> REPUBLICANS ARE EXTREMELY ON
MESSAGE NOW.
AND THEY ARE DANGEROUS.
IT'S TOO MUCH OF A CHANCE AND
THEY ARE AN ANGRY MOB.
THEY WILL TAKE AWAY YOUR
MEDICARE, THIS IS A VERY
INTERESTING CAMPAIGN THAT THEY
HAVE CENTERED ON.
TALKING TO REPUBLICANS AND
WORKING TO KEEP THE HOUSE, THEY
HAVE HAD THE BEST WEEK OR SO
PULLING THAT THEY HAVE HAD IN
QUITE A WHILE.
THEY ATTRIBUTED MOST OF IT TO
THE CAVANAGH EFFECT BUT ALSO
SOME OF IT TO THE TRADE VICTORY,
THEY FELT THAT THE PRESIDENT
FACE DOWN IN CANADA AND ONE.
SO THEY ARE STILL SCARED, THEY
ARE VERY SCARED BUT THEY FEELING
BETTER.
>> FROM THE SAME SHEET OF MUSIC,
USUALLY DEMOCRATS ARE GOOD AT
THAT.
EVERY DAY IT SEEMS LIKE THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT FITS INTO THIS
NARRATIVE THAT THE G.O.P. HAS
CREATED.
ERIC HOLDER, YOU HAVE THE CALLS
FOR IMPEACHMENT FOR BRETT
KAVANAUGH, ALL OF THAT.
>> EVERY TIME ONE DEMOCRAT SAYS,
THIS IS A BIG DEBATE GOING ON
INSIDE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> SHOULD THEY BE MICHAEL
AVENATTI DEMOCRATS?
SHOULD THEY BE THE LEFT-WING
EQUIVALENT OF DONALD TRUMP AND
FIGHT BACK LIKE HE DOES OR
SHOULD THEY STAND FOR SOMETHING
AS MICHELLE OBAMA WOULD SAY,
HIGHER?
THEY DON'T KNOW WHICH DIRECTION
THEY WANT TO GO.
ESPECIALLY IN THE ACTIVIST BASE.
AND IF THIS -- THEY WIN, IT WILL
BE AN EVEN TOUGHER DEBATE.
WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING MORE THEN,
HOW DOES THIS AFFECT ON TUESDAY
NIGHT FOR WEEKS FROM NOW.
THIS IS NOT A GENIE THAT GETS
EASILY PUT BACK IN THE BOTTLE,
IT IS THE EERIE FEELING OF THE
1960s OR 1970s RADICALISM.
WE ARE JUST GETTING IT TO THE
BEGINNING OF SOMETHING THAT IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE CONTAINED
IN FOUR WEEKS.
>> WE ARE COVERING THE MIDTERMS
FOR THE NEXT 47 DAYS.
I ASKED ALL THE PANELS TO CHOOSE
A RACE THAT THEY THINK IS
INTERESTING FOR ONE REASON OR
ANOTHER.
>> I LOOKED AT THE ARIZONA RACE
BECAUSE SUDDENLY, IT'S MORE
PERSONAL TO ME.
>> THIS IS KYRSTEN SINEMA THE
DEMOCRAT MURK VERSUS MICK SALLY
THE REPUBLICAN?
>> YES.
THE NEWS THAT CAME OUT TODAY WAS
THAT SHE HOSTED LYNN STEWART WHO
WAS MY ADVERSARY AND THE BLIND
SHAKE PROSECUTION IN THE
1990s, RISING OUT OF THE
BOMBING OF THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER.
TURNS OUT THAT LYNN WAS LATER ON
TRIAL HERSELF OR MATERIAL
SUPPORT TO TERRORISM FOR
COMMUNICATING MESSAGES FROM THE
BLIND SHAKE, WHERE HE WAS IN
JAIL, TO HIS EGYPTIAN TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION.
THEY TURNS OUT THAT SHE
EVIDENTLY PROMOTED TWO OF HER
APPEARANCES AT UNIVERSITY IN
ARIZONA.
>> WE WILL SEE HOW THAT PLAYS.
YOUR RACE?
>> TREMENDOUS EXCITEMENT AMONG
DEMOCRATS.
O'ROURKE GETS CROWDS OF LIKE
50,000 AND NOBODY THAT I'VE
TALKED TO ACTUALLY THINKS THAT
HE'S GOING TO WIN IT, BUT THE
THING IS, HE'S KIND OF PLOWING
THE FIELDS OR FERTILIZING THE
FIELDS IN TEXAS FOR WHAT
DEMOCRATS HOPE WILL BE
EVENTUALLY THAT STATE TURNING
PURPLE.
THEY'VE BEEN DISAPPOINTED IN THE
PAST BUT THIS TIME THEY THINK
THEY WILL MAKE INROADS.
>> I PICKED THE MONTANA SENATE
RACE, THE INCUMBENT IS THE
SENATE, AND I THINK IT'S THE
BEST CHANCE FOR A REPUBLICAN
PICKUP THAT IS NOT GETTING VERY
MUCH ATTENTION.
THE POLLS ARE VERY, VERY CLOSE
AND REPUBLICANS ARE WAITING FOR
ASP 15 EFFECT.
WE BELIEVE IT WILL TAKE PLACE
AND EARLY VOTING STARTS NEXT
WEEK IN MONTANA.
SO IF THERE IS ANOTHER CAVANAUGH
EFFECT AND WHEN IT'S STRONGEST,